parents and Milwaukee's a city leaders
aren't doing enough to protect their
kids from lead more than 11 percent of
Milwaukee's children in 2016 had lead
poisoning the national average is around
3 percent Wisconsin health officials are
reviewing Milwaukee's lead prevention
program after several reports
highlighted deficiencies in keeping led
away from kids Adriana Diaz is in
Milwaukee and spoke with one concern
family Adrianna good morning good
morning Milwaukee's mayor says lead from
paint is the city's primary concern
because lead-based paint is in at least
a hundred thousand homes here but some
residents and neighborhoods like this
one are worried about lead from pipes
even though the water is treated to keep
the lead out
one Milwaukee family is now dealing with
the dangers of lead poisoning and
they're angry about what they call the
city's slow response
Ameena a Mujahid painstakingly prepares
water for her family filtering it
pitcher by pitcher just an ongoing
process of buying filters and you do it
by hand every day last year her youngest
son Schwab had a blood lead level of
11.4 more than double what's considered
lead poisoning lead can affect IQ and
Amina and her husband nevere believe it
stunted their five-year-old son's brain
development and my assessment
opportunities her son say you look at
you look at you like he's trying to
decide for figure it out but Milwaukee
health officials say lead from paint
poses the greatest risk to local
families but the AL Mujahid's believe
it's in their water after recently
learning they had lead service lines
which supply water to their home the
city says its water meets federal led
standards and is treated to prevent lead
from leaching from pipes improperly
treated water in Flint Michigan caused
widespread lead contamination there
three years ago up to ten million homes
nationwide still have led service lines
even though Congress banned Alette
plumbing supplies more than 30 years ago
about 74,000 are in Milwaukee where the
city has a program to split the cost of
replacing lead pipe
with homeowners but so far only 1% has
been done anytime they touched the water
it's it's alarming for me because I'm
thinking about the exposure their lives
are important to us but it's difficult
to see the city not care the family says
they tried to get a free water filter
under the city's lead program but when
they went
none were left that fits in with a
recent review of the city's LED
prevention program ordered by the mayor
which found insufficient staffing
underfunding and claims of mismanagement
the childhood lead poisoning prevention
program doesn't have records of
investigating about a hundred addresses
where kids blood lead levels reached 20
or higher health officials also don't
know if 4500 families received follow-up
letters with children's led test results
how did these kids slip through the
cracks
well a big part of this we don't know
the answer to Milwaukee Mayor Tom
Barrett I was told by my staff that we
did not have the documentation that
established with certainty that all the
kids had received this letter that was
enough for me to say well then we're
going to send out another reminder oh
that's the problem it's devastating
Wisconsin congresswoman Gwen Moore wants
the federal government to investigate
and has raised concerns over the funding
and effectiveness of Milwaukee's LED
removal programs it's really important
to have this independent audit done by
the Centers for Disease Control mayor
Barrett is not against that idea I
welcome the CDC I welcome the Housing
and Urban Development I think that over
a couple year period we we didn't do
what we needed to do I want to get back
to the basic blocking and tackling Amina
says her family has had to pay the price
for the city's dysfunction we're
supposed to protect our children but I
can't do anything with people that don't
want to meet us halfway we had to do our
own research and do what we can in our
house and buy what we need to clean our
water so wives blood blood levels now
down to a five from an eleven point four
but doctors say there's no safe
level of lead the family is now looking
for a specialist to help with
developmental delays but there are long
wait lists the city has offered to test
the families water but so far the city
hasn't followed up Anthony
Adriana Diaz in Milwaukee eleven percent
of kids with lead poisoning in Milwaukee
that's just makes me furious it makes me
furious I mean this should be like a
five alarm fire going off right now not
for nothing it's not happening in
affluent communities and there's and
there is nothing comforting in that
story for any family that's dealing with
that problem right now